let's create a video streaming app using
the u web framework and rust so this is
the application that we're going to
build
we have two components the component on
the left is the producer
this component communicates with the
webcam grabs the images coming from the
webcam and encodes them using vp9
then it transfers those encoded images
to the consumer
using the use context api
the consumer is responsible for then
decoding these video frames and
presenting them to the user using the
html canvas
this is going to be awesome i promise
first we need to install trunk trunk
will take care of serving our web
application through the browser
next we need to add the wasm target to
rust
now let's create the project
now let's open the project using vs code
let's go ahead and install u
we'll have to delete
like the default main
and create our own first thing to do is
to import
you
then i want to create a functional
component
for those of you that are familiar with
react this should be very very familiar
and now we'll define the
entry point
for the code which is going to be our
good old
main method
now let's go ahead and run this thing
we got the code to load
so
if we change the source code and just
save it
we can see how the page will hot refresh
pretty neat
pretty useful for debugging
one of the challenges of doing wasm
development
is calling the browser javascript apis
from within wasm in this case from rust
luckily
this problem has been solved
there's this beautiful crate called
websites which i found while looking at
the u search code which exposes
all the web apis
let's see if the classes that we need
are exposed or not
so we need video
encoder
check
and video
decoder
so this is very promising let's keep
going and see how far we can get
let's create the skeleton of the
application
what i mean by that is we talked about a
few components that we needed
so let's let's create them and like
position them
[Music]
and
a consumer
[Music]
let's integrate the components with the
app
now i'll add a css class
so that i can create a grid
which contains these two elements
i need to add classes to both the
consumer and the producer so that i can
select them using css
[Music]
cool so the layout is starting to look
like we want it
i do not really care about
black over blue so let's fix it
[Music]
we are now ready to connect the webcam
to accomplish this as i mentioned we
need the syst web library so that we can
interact with the javascript apis
all right let's install websites
to access the javascript libraries we
need to activate individual features
these names here correspond to the
javascript libraries that we want to use
so we'll have to go back and forth
between
our code and our cargo tamil to enable
or activate these features individually
we also need to install wasn't bind gen
so that we can cast between rust objects
and javascript objects
[Music]
this code is to query the media devices
[Music]
here we see that the compiler is
complaining because of media devices
basically doesn't find that method
and that is because we need to activate
media devices
using cargo.tunnel
so now we have code completion which is
great
now we want to
open the webcam so let's let's just go
here we use the
webcam as the id because that's the
id of the video element that we added to
the producer
once again we need to add html video
element to our cargo.tamil
now we need to initialize the streaming
let's add this to the tunnel again
filter
out old media devices but the video
cameras
once again we need to add another
um dom element to the
to the tunnel so that we can execute a
get user
media with user constraints
oh no actually it was wrong the method
is right there
[Music]
to use native javascript objects we need
to install js sys
[Music]
we need to transfer ownership of
constraints
here
now let's
execute the devices query
[Music]
let's enable this feature media
stream also need to install wasom binden
features to do this transform
[Music]
let's wrap this function using a wasn't
binding future
so that we can use async await syntax
just like with tokyo
okay now that we got the device
we just need to plug it to our video
element
we'll we'll go ahead and open a browser
and let's see
if it looks as expected
okay
so yeah i can't see myself behind there
but
let's add some css to fix this
[Music]
yeah that looks a lot better
let's keep going guys
let's bp9 encode this video stream to do
that we'll use the new webcodex
framework that is available since chrome
94 so pretty pretty cutting edge i will
say
we need to get the video track out of
this video element so
[Music]
because we're going to be passing this
element around we create a box pointer
so that we can safely
share it
here we are just selecting
any video track that we can find because
we know that our video device has only
one track so this is fine
let's enable video track
[Music]
now we need to initialize our video
encoder
[Music]
we need to enable video encoder
[Music]
we'll add some console logs to see
what's going on if we get an error
[Music]
this handle will be called when there
are new video frames encoded
[Music]
[Music]
you'll notice that even when we enabled
video encoder init nvidia encoder
in our cargo tunnel
basically
visual studio cannot find these objects
and that's because
it turns out that this is a
an unstable api so we need to pass an
environment variable to
enable it
on top of the feature
being activated
to do that
um we need to open our
settings
dot
json and add a
an environment variable
let's go ahead and reload
hopefully this does the trick we'll see
we need to enable a few more features so
console needs to be enabled too
okay the type of the closure does not
match i know what that is
we need to cast it
[Music]
this operation is unsafe okay for now i
just want to print the thing so let's
just
let's just print the chunk
let's configure the video encoder
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so now that we configured our video
encoder we need to feed it
with the video frames or i'm sorry with
the images coming from the camera
to that effect we'll use a midi stream
track processor
so let's go
so
processor
[Music]
let's enable all these things
all right now for some reason vs code is
extremely angry
so let's see why
it says that media stream track
processor does not have
these features
which is kind of weird because it's
chilled
um
[Music]
stream
stream processor
media stream
media stream
track processor
so yeah it should be there but it is not
there
and if we look at the source code
jesus go away okay if we look at the
source code we can see that for some
reason
they did not ship the library with media
stream processor
media stream track event
so media streamed track processor is not
there
but do not worry what we're going to do
is
we're going to clone their repo and add
it as our dependency to our code
i'm going to show you how to use cargo
patch
so that we can like
uh
use
a newer version of this library straight
from get
let's go
i just want to verify that
this object is available on github like
the object that we're looking for
[Music]
it is available on github so
so what we're going to do is clone the
entire wasn't binding repository to our
computer and then reference it from the
project
so git
clone
and we just get the url from the website
so
just get this thing here
okay
now
we need to reference it from our
cargo.tamil
using
cargo a patch i think
[Music]
all right so it looks like it is still
angry
and that's because of this space here
fantastic we got our processor to work
now let's add a reader
so the reader
will pull the frames out of the stream
and send them to the encoder
[Music]
we need to add a bunch of classes to our
tunnel file
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then we either get a frame back or
not so this is
the js frame
then we do something with it or we get
an error
[Music]
if we do get a frame back then we want
to cast it as a video frame
and then we want to unwrap it as a
video frame
and checked
into
video frame
[Music]
this is to prevent leaks so we passed
the video frame to the encoder and we
indicate that we are no longer going to
use it
and forgot what to match on so we might
we want to match unresolved
all right the compiler says that encode
does not exist
why why would that be let's see i cannot
click on video frames i'm not sure if i
forgot to add it here yeah i forgot to
add video frame here
one more compiler error
this is js
frame
now if we open a browser and go to the
website
[Music]
we should see the
the video frames
inspect
and we see all the
so here we see all the video chunks
coming out from the encoder
so this is looking great
all right now we need to ship the frames
from the producer component to the
consumer
and as we said at the beginning of the
suite of this video we'll be using the
use context hook that u exposes is just
like the react use context hook so let's
just go for it we're going to create
our context inside the producer
well we're going to instantiate it
inside the producer
so
[Music]
all right so this is our video context
now we are referencing a type that
doesn't exist yet
encoded video chunk wrapper so let's
let's create this structure
so we're going to use this type to
wrap the encoded video frames and send
them to the consumer
it needs to implement a bunch of
traits
so we need clone
copy
partial equal
and we want we need to implement a
reducer
[Music]
and we need to write to this video
context when we get a new frame so here
[Music]
now we need to wrap our dom with the
provider
[Music]
we need to create our
component
[Music]
we are almost done guys we just need to
build the consumer let's go
let's go ahead and subscribe to the
context
[Music]
so we'll use this second
variable to store
the video decoder
[Music]
so if the video decoder is none we'll go
ahead and initiate and initialize it
[Music]
let's add this to the
terminal file actually these three video
decoder video decoder config and
build decoder in it
[Music]
this requires two functions
it requires an error video
and an
output
we'll define this
later but we need these two variables
then we initialize the video decoder
then we initialize the video decoder
config
video codec
same codec that we use for the
encoder
[Music]
and then we save an instance
let's define these two functions
so
err
error video
[Music]
[Music]
first thing we're going to do is to
create a box
pointer because we are going to use this
chunk
in a couple of functions
[Music]
now we need to hit the width and height
from the video so that we can
render it correctly to the canvas
[Music]
[Music]
let's select the canvas from the dom
[Music]
as always let's add this to the manifest
html
canvas element
then we're going to set
the width and the height
[Music]
finally we are just going to render the
image
[Music]
[Music]
after rendering the frame we're going to
close it
beautiful
and we want to bring it there
all right i missed a couple of
semi-colons so here
and here
save
and let's move on to the
final stage
so
here all we are going to do
is
receive the frames from the producer
so if the video chunk
is not none then parts it
now we are going to read the data
from the chunk we need to initialize a
vector
to store the data
[Music]
the encoder takes encoded video chunk
objects so we need to pass that to it
final
line of code other than fixing compiler
issues in code
encoded
video chunk
now
let's fix all the compile errors but
this is it this is all the code
we'll see
okay so we are missing this import here
canvas
blah blah
right one more error here is our
video vector
that was making
this
fix this variable name here
all right couple of details here
we need to
unwrap this
and cast
these functions
all right one more buck here
we need to unwrap this video context too
yeah those options are really kicking
our ass
okay this one is funny
here i want to initialize the vector
with size chunk
chunk dot byte length
so i need to change this by a semi colon
it's just one of those things
and here we want to decode not any code
all right so at least now it compiles
let's see what we got
jesus
you're getting an exception
i can't i can feel it
a bunch of uncut exceptions
that's because
guess what
some of our
callbacks are being released
so what we need to do is to retain them
to actually to forget them so that they
don't get released
after assigning the functions here we'll
just say err
video
forget
the final bug i found is that we were
setting the video streaming over and
over
because there's nothing that prevents
this piece of code from being called
multiple times so using the use effect
api
will ensure that we get called only once
[Music]
all right so let's reload the page
okay so the aspect ratio is obviously
wrong but at least
like the page is not constantly
refreshing so let's take care of these
things
so first thing we want to do
is
let's
fix the
css
and like
lock the the width of the
canvas
all right
so
let's fix the aspect ratio we should be
good to go
all right to fix the aspect ratio we
need to fix these coordinates here
not discarding its values so this is
720
by 1280
so they were backwards
all right let's specify the
width and height settings
let's ensure in the tunnel file that we
have media stream track settings so we
do have media tracks settings make sure
to add this else it won't work
[Music]
okay it works now let me share some
conclusions about this project
all right so i have four points to share
with you
point number one the u framework is
awesome it works the syntax is
comparable to react so great job you
team this is amazing
number two
i remember when typescript came out
and it feels similar to this but better
let me explain myself
when typescript came out you spent a lot
of time trying to figure out the types
and like bind them to javascript types
which we did the same here
but based on the
size of this project
like all the wasam initiatives
i believe that while typescript was more
like an incremental enhancement
enhancement to javascript this is more
of a leap using rust is a leap for web
developers
number three
i felt extremely comfortable using the
web frameworks
i found types for
most of them so we're talking web
codecs web transport webrtc all these
libraries that i personally use
so great job team
number four i did spend
a lot of time compiling so that was not
amazing but pretty sure the the team is
working on it so great job
thank you for watching see you in the
next one
you